okay William FS Ben Affleck how can we
get the US government to take stronger
action against the murders in the Congo
yeah I know that you you've been to the
Congress I've been to the Congress Oh
his nick in fact Nick's work writing the
New York Times inspired me to travel
there for the first time spent a lot of
time since there Nick does this similar
kind of work that's great play that's a
tough play it is a tough place like like
a lot of places in Africa and around
developing world and I think one of the
things the simplest thing to say is to
start caring about it talk to friends
about develop a constituency talk to
your representatives about what their
position is on foreign aid listen to and
not just one aid but you know there's a
way that we can engage with many of
these countries for free which is our
diplomacy there's kind of a zero-sum
game of our diplomats are paying
attention to a lot of different things
all at once China India Pakistan
Afghanistan and things just get lost in
the shuffle if there's enough of a
constituency saying like hold on a
second you know we're interesting you're
paying attention to this you can have
you know John Kerry or President States
engaging on a high-level diplomatic
initiative with for example the Congo
and you could address some of these
needs they're very complicated they're
ongoing
Nick's more expert about it than I am
what is the situation there now I mean
honestly I haven't read a lot about it
in the last year I mean one of the
problems is that we in the news business
are essentially dropping the ball on the
world and you know television isn't
covering the news anymore and so that is
makes it incumbent upon people to use
social media to use other ways to hold
us accountable but also to hold
government's accountable because Congo
is a place you know the most lethal
conflicts it's world war two and we
can't solve it entirely we can certainly
mitigate it and reduce the death toll
and that's going to require but you're
so right about dropping the ball on the
especially TV news I mean the nightly
news used to complain that they only had
a half-hour - how did we cover the world
they only put news in the first slug
I saw NBC Nightly News with Brian
Williams who this week the last whole
segment was an interview with Ben
Affleck [ __ ] huh
I mean
we love Ben Affleck but it does John
astray you shouldn't get an interview
with your on go not Kongo but it goes to
what we were talking about before if
it's if we said I knew it we prioritize
was an aside love a cycle is about that
long it's a 24 hour maybe a 36 hour news
cycle but that's what super versus we
have a 24-hour cable media and they
never seem to be able to talk about the
same thing for 110 seconds so you get
nothing in depth it's just the endless
cycling and the book if you were in and
when we come back and you'll buy all the
picture and a little interview and
there's no in-depth coverage you have 24
talking hours to put on the air you come
into tippet that's the problem statement
news used to be a loss leader that's
right William Paley said I don't make
money from the news that's what I have
the Beverly Hillbillies for absolutely
the government gave 10 Network right the
broadcast right now said okay well
everybody has to put into the kiddie
show that the Shakers news entertainment
the same thing you know standing right
yeah then I'm looking combined right and
me I mean obviously I had a hand in
creating that problem but at least I my
defense was always at least if people
watch this show and don't watch news
that all they're getting some news right
well if they aren't is that people get
more news from this show and Stewart
right it's like if there's not many
shows that's what you see in the
Millennials with Colbert and in The
Daily Show that's where they get a lot
of their news from because there is
content no school I just said that's
always fun
actually yet I think we have more
viewers than tho show you did it's okay
yeah it's just you know just keep
quoting it quoting a tease yeah you got
it what's one thing positive thing about
Detroit you want to share with the
nation been since you've been filming
Batman you know a lot I mean Detroit's
an amazing city in the one hand it's
like you look at it you know Detroit is
like a place where we talk about us
nation building I look around I eat
around blocks and blocks there's one
house that's being lived in that's our
pitch we'll come bring your build your
nation look what we did for Detroit and
we have a whole America Cydia virtually
lying fallow and science a industrial
sector has fallen nearly completely
apart so parts was devastating and I was
shocked that we just even allow me the
UN had to step in because the Detroit
turned off the water to hundreds of
thousands people said oh you can't do
this water is a basic human right you
can't turn people's water off but the
truth is like I visit a bunch of auto
plants and I've spent a lot of time in
the city and there is a tremendous like
comeback can-do spirit that has actually
been really really inspiring to me so
it's a sort of the blight why is the
movie being filmed there the movie you'd
have to talk to the filmmakers but a
part of what Michigan has done is to
take on a you know Michigan like others
day they need a kind of a poster but
they're trying to build a no I'm asking
that maybe
they're out there they're staging the
Michigan they're trying to build a film
infrastructure solstice Batman is
Superman a fighting they wreck the whole
city and that's what they did
Thanks they had it kind of back in
trying to spear that Tamar [ __ ] on it no
no no no no I love Detroit okay uh what
with the way we favor war in this
country it would be best to bring back
the draft yeah definitely yeah yeah
everybody needs know all strata of
American willing to absorb the cost of
war action my kids middle-class kids
poor kids right not just this tiny
stripes urchins excited national service
would be a great idea but the problem is
the military now is so specialized that
simply having everybody in it a wouldn't
create a great military but also then
creates more reserves and then more
likely to be deployed I think the
political benefits of work is that
everyone go no no no yet go to generals
don't want the draft and why is that
okay because what is more effective
force one you want a smaller force stays
and longer well it worked in World War
two they drafted I give back more ten
people right yeah it's a very different
strategy I mean this this is military is
much more technologically driven so you
have you need fewer people because
you've got the equipment to do it this
idea that by having a volunteer service
we're getting the cream of the crop to
sign up it's not exactly true either
what we're getting is people who very
often don't have any other options in
life Oh
Teach for America is a great program
those kids kick ass I don't know but I
mean I think the military can take
anybody and turn them into the
military's badass they don't walk around
right serious [ __ ] that right no they
don't just take anybody anymore
they don't that's that's actually they
did lower their standards on weight and
drug use that maybe which one were you
on that yeah that's right that they just
but don't don't you know get this idea
that they just take anybody who walks in
that's not just like half of young
people now no longer qualify for the
military right but I think it's it's
nuts about a tactical game look the
United States Armed Forces could defeat
any standing army in the world in
conventional warfare almost immediately
and overnight we have the world's best a
view of they'll be best standing army
the most proficient equipped soldiers in
the world the only thing is United
States fails at our situations where use
a military approach isn't an exact fit
like nation-building and so on and so
forth
so I think the political cost of saying
okay you know what you want to support a
war gigantic war where we're all gonna
go fight even the generals like we don't
need all these kids it means that the
congressman's kid and Senators kid and
rich guides kid and and the hedge fund
guys kid also have to go and do that
cost well right I think the purchase
that I agree with that I grew that the
first mistake though that we've seen
since since 9/11 is that we tend to use
our military for the purposes of
nation-building and that's not the
purpose of a military it is to blow up
things and to and to we're a very
conquest and then you pull it out and
then the diplomat and the
government-to-government relations are
all about what those who are there on
the ground want their nation to be and
you cannot impose that to a military and
we've learned a dear lesson because of
it alright let me ask you one final
question and put on your chairman of the
Republican Party hat for one Capital
excellent economic news that we got this
week of 5.9%
is the unemployment rate yeah it was
lower home 40,000 jobs cream right it
was lower that rate was only lower
during one year of st. Reagan's two
terms
yeah but look where it was at the
beginning of Reagan's term so
double-digit inflation double-digit
where it was at the beginning of Obama I
know and but again I take your point and
there have been strides me but it's the
type of recovery that is still the
driver here and you do have people who
have not felt you still have so many you
still have five million people who were
unemployed in 2008 that are still
unemployed today and that is a reality
for a lot of folks out there so is the
stagnation in the growth and it is due
to a couple of things one the failure to
address tax policy minimum wage the
failure to address regulatory policy and
to create the kind of incentives that
require us to manufacture again allow us
to milk sound like a family sound like
making it in your gut also actually very
very Republican persuaded Eisenhower and
but your four-eyes I mean Nixon wanted
universal health care I mean it did
things that yeah well here's the result
of this policy is that it is a little
bit like what senator Warren said a game
that is rigged I was here again 2004 I
remember talking about this saying these
Bush tax cuts are saving me millions and
millions of dollars and if they continue
on for four more you're gonna save
millions and millions and millions
dollars what job is my going to create
another assistant you know what I mean I
I'm an actor I make movies but I'm just
going to get more money so even if I go
make the movies that doesn't change of
course the Bush tax cut that I get and
I'm like a lot of other wealthy people
who just got buckets of money dumped on
them by the Bush administration for
virtually no enhanced societal
contribution and as such that these
positive continued the estate tax being
eliminated what I think was devastating
to the redistribution the Pajero it
might be detention if you want well you
know I know it's not an issue
no I can't risk it yes you can you know
hear you iris is not gonna turn your
check away that's not how were I did
yeah that's a dumb argument no it's not
I just want to say if someone don't
Morgan goes to that Netflix list every
night trying to find a good movie you
need to keep making poop but you got it
right
I'll be soft all right thank you
everybody thank you what is nothing huh